good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today is scp
2764
object class
ketter
special containment procedures scp-2764
is currently located in
antarctica all civilians are to be kept
outside of a 150 kilometer radius from
the object this radius is to be strictly
monitored by a mobile task force eta 5
containment battalion 4 alpha
a perimeter has been established around
a radius of 75 kilometers from scp-2764
and this perimeter is to be guarded by
at least 10 guards per 25 kilometers of
the circumference at all times totaling
a 190 guard minimum around the entire
circumference if any civilian is caught
inside of the 150 kilometer radius they
are to be brought in for questioning and
are to be administered class a or b
amnestics at the discretion of the
on-site supervisor the civilian in
question will then be transported
off-site to their most recent dwelling
should scp scp-2764
suddenly flicker outside of the usual
radius of 25 kilometers a new perimeter
is to be immediately established at the
radius of 75 kilometers and this
perimeter shall be held with the usual
containment procedures until
scp-2764 returns to its usual position
in the event that the creature flickers
to a public location all civilians are
to be immediately evacuated and all
known observers of the event will be
taken in and administered class a
amnestics the area should from there on
out be monitored for any traces of
knowledge of scp-2764
in the populace and civilians suspected
to have knowledge about the event are to
be monitored very closely and eventually
administered class b amnestics at the
earliest convenience
under absolutely no circumstances is any
foundation employee or civilian to
approach closer than 30 kilometers to
the creature if any person is found to
have approached closer than this
distance they are to be detained
immediately and questioned thoroughly
the person in question is to be given a
thorough psychological evaluation and is
to then either be administered class a
amnestics or to be terminated after the
consideration of their evaluation
description
scp-2764 is a massive biological entity
of unknown origin its height measures to
be approximately 382 meters and is
estimated to weigh over 150 000 metric
tons the entity possesses between 75 and
85 tenticular appendages extending from
the ventral region of its body it uses
this mass of tendrils for both movement
and simple utility actions such as
picking objects up the organism appears
to move as if it were a quadripetal
mammal that is the ventral cavity of its
body faces the ground and the dorsal
cavity faces the opposite direction the
organism also appears to have a cranial
extrusion which is hypothesized to
contain its brain but there is no
backing data for this and the only
organs visible on its head are its eyes
of which it possesses four two on each
half of the facial region
aside from
scp-2764's clear violation of the
theoretical limit to a biological
organism's size on earth its anomalous
properties include the following
scp-2764 possesses the ability to
telepathically communicate the language
in which it communicates is dependent on
the listener
scp-2764 however does not appear to
understand any messages it receives in
response
scp-2764 size does not appear to follow
euclidean geometries that is one cannot
distinguish the organism's true size
based on simply looking at it as the
creature will often appear to be many
times smaller or larger than estimates
determine it to be there is a critical
zone which lies approximately 50
kilometers in diameter from
scp-2764 as an individual approaches the
bound of this zone from the inside
scp-2764 will appear to blow up or grow
larger outside of this zone
scp-2764 will begin to shrink as the
distance from the edge of the critical
zone grows larger
scp-2764's appendages appear to rapidly
translocate themselves inexplicably they
will also transpose with each other's
positions in space at very rapid
intervals whether this has a relation to
the previous anomaly mentioned is as of
yet unknown
lastly and perhaps the most noteworthy
scp-2764's position will flicker on
occasion though the frequency of this
event is unknown as it appears to occur
on a completely unsystematic basis the
location of
scp-2764 has never flickered further
than 25 kilometers and the object has
always flickered back to its original
location within 48 hours
recovery summary
scp-2764 was discovered by civilian
and his team during a detailed survey on
the antarctic terrain
he observed the anomaly and noted its
odd geometries and then returned to base
he shared news of the occurrence
who was the foundation's investigative
researcher in antarctica at the time
immediately reported this to his
superior officer at which point mobile
task force eta 5 was sent to the
antarctic base to administer amnestics
to the local populace and secure a small
perimeter around scp-2764
the initial perimeter was too small and
commander mann who was at the time the
commander of mobile task force eta 5
took it upon himself to investigate the
odd creature
man's investigation is outlined in the
investigative logs that follow
investigative log days one to three
day one
subject appears to shrink as we get
closer to it which is strange because it
was growing until we got to a certain
point
also its horrifically large tentacles
move in a particularly strange manner i
plan to investigate further in the
coming days and hopefully do a bit of my
own research before they send in the
main researchers and guards to take over
signed j-man
day two
last night as i tried to sleep i kept
hearing a
strange voice while i cannot currently
recall what it was saying i i'm sure it
had something to do with the beast out
there
i personally see no other explanation as
i was alone and i have no history of
hearing voices
signed
day two afternoon
i've gathered a few volunteers from the
task force our job is to secure the
anomaly until the main guards can get
here not research it so i won't be
forcing anyone to come along with me but
it's not against my orders to carry out
some extra research and i wouldn't mind
having some other folks investigating
with me always better to have more than
one person when it comes to witnessing
events i managed to convince three other
guys to come with me i plan to approach
the anomaly very closely and i made this
very clear to everyone as i announced
that i needed volunteers
we will begin our exploration tomorrow
signed j mann
day two evening
i'm hearing this voice again it's
currently about 10 o'clock p.m and i'm
trying to comprehend what it is saying
it's like it's
speaking in english and i know it is but
just can't work out what it's saying
signed man
day three
one of the guys that volunteered came to
my tent in the early hours of the
morning and said he couldn't go through
with it
i told him that it was fine and i don't
blame him when i asked him why he
changed his mind though he told me that
he'd been hearing something talking to
him last night and suspected that it was
connected to the anomaly when i heard
about this i asked him if he knew what
it was saying he said he couldn't recall
exactly what it was saying but its words
evoked a terrible fear in him that he
never wished to experience again when i
inquired he also stated that it was
speaking english but again he can't
recall what it's saying exactly i then
revealed that i too had been hearing
voices but had not been terrified by
them this did not convince him to stay
on the exploration team with us but it
seemed to comfort him that he was not
the only one hearing things
i hope the other two are still in for it
signed man
day three afternoon i asked the other
guys if they experienced anything out of
the ordinary in the past few days and
neither of them said that they had this
is a good thing for me as i'll have a
couple of companions on my research
venture
but i also feel like i'll be lying to
them if they haven't experienced the
voices i won't tell them about the
voices myself as i fear they'll get
spooked out of coming with me but on the
same token they volunteered to venture
very closely to a large horrible
creature so maybe the story about the
voices won't deter them for now i'll
proceed with discretion
signed j-man
day three evening we set out around four
o'clock in the afternoon
and the other two guys seemed as excited
to get closer to the thing as i was
apprehensive don't get me wrong i too
was excited
it just seemed like they were a little
too excited i guess it isn't out of
character for those two as we got closer
indeed the thing kept growing smaller
which sort of cooled my anxiety for a
bit but then we started seeing oddities
in the snow of course we were dealing
with a giant anomaly but the snow prince
just seemed off
there wasn't anything wrong with their
pattern they just seemed out of place
signed j-man
investigative log days four to six
day four
we set up camp about a quarter way to
the thing the snow was deep and thick
and to be honest i was surprised we made
it even a quarter of the way
no signs of any voices heard by myself
or the other two last night i'm making
sure to be very discreet when i ask them
about any oddities i don't want to put
up a red flag
signed j-man
day four afternoon we covered about half
the distance we did yesterday so i'd say
we're close to halfway there
about three-eighths of the way to be
exact the snow is getting deeper as we
approach the thing it continues to
shrink as we approach it so nothing too
out of the ordinary thus far with the
exception of the out-of-place prince and
the snow none of us can work out what
creature they originate from
yesterday i i thought they were human
tracks
signed nj man
day four evening a particularly quiet
evening nothing notable has occurred
signed j-man
day five
one of the guys reported that he'd heard
some strange voices last night i asked
him what they were saying before i
revealed that i too had been hearing
voices
he told me they were unintelligible i
expected this but it is now getting
quite frustrating that no one can
decipher what the voices are saying
hopefully this expedition to the
thing out there will bring us more
information
signed man
day five afternoon
we made very little progress today
we neglected to bring our tissue
analyzer from the last tent we set up so
we had to go back
we'll be back on track hopefully by the
day after tomorrow signed j-man
day five evening the evening is quiet
once again i've heard no voices thus far
and the tracks in the snow were absent
during our trek back to the old tent
today
signed j mann
day five midnight i've been lying awake
for some time now and i've realized that
something was horribly out of the
ordinary i recall that as we approached
the thing it got smaller
while i would expect it to grow larger
as we put more distance between it and
ourselves the problem is
it has not grown larger since this
morning when we left to return to the
tent
signed j-man
day six
the first opportunity i had i told the
other guys about my realization and i
asked what they thought we should do
there was some debate but ultimately we
came to the decision to continue forth
toward the creature on top of this i can
report that we have all now heard the
voices the last guy finally heard them
last night
once again they were incomprehensible to
no surprise of course i hold the belief
that we will eventually discover what
the voices are saying
but for now
we trek on
signed j-man
day six
afternoon
we made it back to the point we left
from yesterday and decided to continue
on for a little while longer the
creature has continued to shrink
even as we traveled the same path we
traveled the day before yesterday the
spatial anomaly is starting to get
eerily disheartening
signed j-man
day six evening the creature has
disappeared we all agree that it was due
southeast but we've checked the
compasses again and again but the thing
is just no longer there i hypothesize
that it has grown so small that we can
no longer see it but the other two guys
think it's just disappeared regardless
we all agreed to continue in the
direction we were handed we will
continue on for a day and if it has not
reappeared at that point
then i see no reason to continue
we'll
just have to go back
signed j mann
investigative log days seven to nine
day seven once again i have heard the
voice it is now distinguishable as a
single voice as opposed to more than one
as i previously believed
some of the words were actually
comprehensible and memorable but they
were simple things which actually made
no sense when put together the most
distinct words were
snow
and back the latter is especially eerie
but i can't think anything of it as
there was no context when i inquired the
other two guys had also heard the voice
and came to the same conclusions as i
had
signed
man
day seven afternoon we've continued on
for some time now but it's only three
o'clock the creature has reappeared
where we expected it to be and it has
grown considerably smaller since we last
muted so i conclude that whatever
occurred that affected its position did
not affect the shrinkage anomaly we look
to be about three-fourths of the way
there now we will continue till about
five o'clock
signed j-man
day seven
afternoon
it's five o'clock and two oddities have
occurred one we have all agreed the past
two hours were definitely a longer
duration than the last two hours on top
of space the creature must incur a
temporal anomaly as well strangely
enough however this is the first time
any temporal anomaly has been noticed by
myself or the other two second of all
and most disturbing are the tracks in
the snow
they reappeared last night but i thought
nothing of it as it is a normality at
this point but the tracks are definitely
no longer human at this point or
anything of this earth the closest thing
i can think of is perhaps a
squid which walks on land considering
that the creature out there has
tenticular appendages i suppose this
isn't too much of a surprise but it's
still certainly frightening
i'm interested in following them
but i want to get to the creature above
all else the main guards were supposed
to arrive this morning but i see no sign
of them thus far
i suppose they're just not visible to us
or perhaps the temporal anomaly has
affected our view of time at any rate i
expect to arrive at the creature's
location by tomorrow if things go
optimally this expedition has certainly
exceeded its expected duration
signed j-man
day seven
evening
new tracks have appeared around our tent
none of us heard anything out of the
ordinary myself and one of the guys
agreed that those tracks were not there
before but the other guy recalls their
existence before this occurrence we all
have to be more mindful of things like
this it's beginning
it's beginning to become more dangerous
than it already was and i suspect
something sinister about these newfound
tracks
man
day eight
we awoke early this morning to get a
head start
once again new tracks appeared in the
snow this time none of us had any doubt
of their non-existence beforehand if we
do not make it to the creature within
two days
we'll abandon the trek and begin to
follow the tracks
i fear for our safety at this point
we should be back at the base greeting
the new guards and allowing them to take
over
j-man
day eight afternoon it is twelve o'clock
and we have made it about nine tenths of
the way there
the creature continues to shrink but
we are definitely very close at this
point
we're going to take a brief break and
get a few hours of sleep in before we
continue on we should lose little time
thanks to the timbrel anomaly
j man
day 8 midnight
our reliance on the temporal anomalies
stability has failed us it is currently
midnight but we only got a couple of
hours sleep
i made the decision to continue forth
my fear for my own safety and more
importantly my fear for their safety has
grown to the point where i will have to
take full control
of this expedition no more votes i will
take their opinions into consideration
but my word will be final from this
point on
day eight to nine transition early
morning
day nine 9
as we continued to walk the voice made a
very clear statement to all of us this
is not verbatim as i could never hope to
remember every incomprehensible word
this horrible creature has spoken to us
and i apologize for my fakeness but we
got the intended message
turn back
no doubt at this point these words are
those of the creature we hope to reach
the tone of the voice did not imply any
sort of anger or even a hint of
territorial jealousy
it sounded more fearful than anything
else
man
day nine
once again the creature has disappeared
i do not credit this occurrence to its
shrinkage this time around i am certain
that we would still be able to see this
behemoth even at this small size from
this distance i'm certain of that
to be truthful
i've
had enough of this supplies are not a
problem we brought plenty to last i'm
just seriously worried about our safety
not only is the anomaly a main issue but
the antarctic is a frigid stark place we
have made it thus far with no serious
complaints about the cult but i worry
that i will not last much longer i have
made the decision to lead us in the
direction of the tenticular tracks
regardless of whether the creature
reappears or not which i am certain it
will i feel as though
we will not make any more progress
towards the creature itself and its
eerie statement last night has seriously
stricken terror in me after i've given
it more thought
joseph mann
day nine
morning
the tracks have led us back to one of
our oldest tents the one at which we
left the tissue analyzer
i am thoroughly confused at this
first of all and most obvious it took us
three hours to travel a distance which
previously took us five or six days to
travel
second of all i noticed no human tracks
as you may have expected to see as a
result of our previous trek back to this
tent
i will continue to record things in this
log to the best of my ability
but my focus has shifted from
researching this beast to getting us
back to base safely
joseph mann
day nine before noon something has been
following us this entire time since day
one to be frank i don't care about this
thing out there any longer something has
been following us and this explains the
strange tracks in the snow this must be
why those tracks led us back to our old
tent we were not following them forward
we were following them backward
joseph
day nine
afternoon i have come to the realization
that i am now
alone where i once heard the comforting
sound of human footsteps crunching the
snow behind me
i now hear nothing but the hollow wind
and emptiness i cannot recall at what
point those two got away from me or
perhaps at what point i got away from
them but now i am terrified of what is
to come
i still have plenty of supplies packed
and as previously stated food and water
will be relatively no issue for at least
the next fortnight but i
am alone the tracks in the snow are now
more terrifying than ever and the voice
more horrific than before
joseph
leave
day nine afternoon i lost my log in the
snow a few hours ago it was a simple
mishap but i recovered it without any
incident it was a little wet but
otherwise untouched i just took notice
of the one word entry above
i'm trying to work out at what point i
entered this but i can't recall the
point at which i did this for the life
of me
joseph
day 9 late afternoon it feels like it's
been days since i last updated this log
but i know it cannot have been as the
sun has not said and i've only eaten one
meal since that time to be frank
day nine
late afternoon it was a requirement for
me to abruptly end my last entry
i heard movement circling me and upon
closer investigation i saw the beast the
beast itself was circling me as fast as
i could i approached the thing and
skinned a sample of tissue off its torso
before it could skitter off with its
horrible [ __ ] tentacles
the tissue analyzer came up as zero that
is
the tissue analyzer recorded no
difference between this creature's
tissue and a human's tissue
i will have to run some confidence tests
on this because i refuse to believe it
until all evidence points to this thing
being
somehow related to humans
joseph
day nine evening i've set up a tent i
want to get my mind off this situation
for a small while i've set up a lantern
and strewn out a towel on which i will
eat to dinner and read a book
then i will get back to the walk
and i will likely skip sleep tonight
joseph
day 9 midnight the book seemed to quiet
the voice
it was a peaceful hour but i knew that i
would have to leave as soon as i could
the sooner i get back to base the sooner
they can analyze all of this data from
the tissue analyzer and make a sound
conclusion about the tissue my personal
belief is that my analyzer is broken but
i've stored the tissue in my pack so the
guys at the base should have no issue
running it through again
joseph
investigative log days 10 to 11.
day 10 i'm almost back to base but i see
some guys coming over the snow hill i
assume they're looking for me so
i need to warn them not to go any
further inward
joseph
day ten
morning
these folks are approaching me awfully
slowly
they've taken to setting up a camp which
is strange because if they're looking
for me which is undoubtedly the case
then they are taking an unnecessary
break as i am no more than half a mile
away
day 10 before noon they made some slow
but steady progress towards my location
and then they decided to turn back i
suspect that the spatial anomaly is
affecting our distance because as i
stated previously we're only about half
a mile apart
why are they turning back
i haven't a clue
day 10 afternoon
a few things
the tracks in the snow have disappeared
as with the voice
i've gotten far enough away from the
thing i assume and the beast has
reappeared about southeast
exactly where it should be it's
strangely comforting but i still intend
to return to the base
day 10 evening the three guys are now
approaching me again they make frequent
stops which i suppose i don't blame them
i must be miles away from their
perspective but it is certain they are
coming for me now i know they can see me
day 10
midnight
at this point i have absolutely giving
up traveling on my own progress is
heavily stymied by this special anomaly
i make it barely a few feet after a long
day of travel
i'm very scared
and i hope these guys can make it to me
before my supplies run out which is now
a concern
day 11 i'm currently very frightened i
want these guys to turn back i know
what's happened i don't know how it
happened but it did
i will write more on my suspicions once
i recover sufficient evidence for them
but for now i say this for future
reference i do not know how this
happened
day 11 early morning i recovered a
journal in the snow i know my suspicion
to be true at this point
what i discovered in the journal was
horrible i refused to write any of its
contents here i scrawled a warning in it
as quickly as i could
i know who will find it
day 11 late morning
the travelers disappeared and then
reappeared again
i tried to approach the lone wanderer in
person to notify him to turn back but
this was to no avail as he was hostile
and proceeded to cut a chunk out of my
back
i had no clue how to react to this i
just ran away
this realization is too horrible for me
to stay plainly my suspicions have all
been but confirmed it all adds up
the tissue analyzer coming up at zero
the transition of human tracks in the
snow to those tentacular
things
something occurred
the time in space is all messed up due
to this beast
i will leave this to the consideration
of the reader whoever finds this log
i hope it is not me this time
okay
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
anvil
aletreon
derivative
zargeron
professor puffer
retalias
tailored printers
clad the lad
perpetually confused mate tech pilot
signor
your local foundation agent
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
a real american hebrew
sayo dio damnatis
eric corbige
longinus
the morrigan
karim el ashmuy
james saba
and nj bojack if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos and some other cool stuff as
well visit patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you